il faut savoir quand même que tous en
fait en réalité on a fait l'expérience
du dérèglement climatique ne serait-ce
qu'à travers les les les épisodes de
canicule il faut savoir que lors des
épisodes caniculaires il y a une
augmentation de la fréquentation des
urgences psychiatrique qui fait x 7 donc
c'est x 7 passages aux urgences
psychiatriques il y a des
décompensations qui sont plus fréquentes
pour nos patients donc des patients qui
ont des troubles psychiatriques connus
qui leur des épisodes caniculaires vont
avoir des symptômes qui vont s'ug qui
vont augmenter et qui vont nécessiter
des prises en charge et il faut savoir
qu'il y a un risque de mortalité qui est
multiplié par 3 pour nos patients
pendant les les épisodes caniculaires
donc tous en fait on a déjà été
confronté aux effets du dérèglement
climatique dans notre propre chair
puisque là ça fait plusieurs étés que on
traverse des épisodes caniculaires ça ça
a été assez bien documenté